well everyone and welcome to my if-else
basics tutorial video for Python 3 the
idea of the if-else pairing is to add
one more layer of logic to the usage of
your if statement here so the else
statement can actually be used in quite
a few other ways like with wow 4 and
another one we haven't even covered yet
and that's except here are the basic
idea is to ask if something is the case
like we did before if it is the case do
something otherwise do something else so
in this case let's just you know print
stuff out so to start let's define a
couple variables again so we'll say X
equals 5 y equals 8 again and now let's
say if X is greater than Y print X is
greater than Y and then we come down
here and we say else and there's really
nothing more to it you don't have to tie
these to each other or anything like
that Python just will automatically
understand that they go together and if
you put multiple if statements which
I'll show you in a little bit it will
only apply to that most recent if so
more on that in a little bit but else
print X is not greater than Y so let's
save and run this and we see X is indeed
not greater than Y this if statement
never ran and because this if statement
never ran the else was triggered but if
we flip this around and we ran it um we
got X is greater than Y even though it's
less than but we flip the sign but with
this else statement never ran because
this if statement ran but the same thing
that you can do is you could say you can
run this if statement and then you could
obviously you could throw in another if
statement so if X is greater than 55
ring X is greater and 55 say if run and
what we get here is X is greater than Y
and then X is not greater than Y so this
if statement because we left it like
this ran but now if we run it the only
thing that runs is the else statement
but if we make this statement a true
statement so X is less than 55 and we
run it
we get X is greater than 55 and nothing
else so this if statement never ran but
because this if statement ran the else
did not run so as long as it's triggered
that else is not going to run so that
brings up the next question for some
people is one how can you enter or how
should you enter multiple if statements
in here and then also what if you
actually only need like one if statement
like if you want to have like if
something is the case or if something
else is the case or if something else is
the case do something otherwise you know
do something so multiple ifs and then
else but these multiple ifs are tied
together kind of as one big if you know
so to do something like that you would
actually use a new command and that is
going to be the Elif statement otherwise
you know it's short for else if and
that's what we're going to be talking
about in the next video so as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support in the subscriptions and stay
tuned to the next video